Just before we get started with today's video,
I want to thank brilliant for sponsoring it to support biographics and learn
more about brilliant.
Go to brilliant.org/biographics and sign up for free.
Galileo.
Galileo was a truth seeker.
His quest for truth though was to bring him into conflicts with the most
powerful institution of his day,
the Roman Catholic Church.
Through such interventions as the telescope he revealed truths that landed him
in front of the Holy Roman inquisition.
Fighting for is very survival condemned during his life.
He has now revealed as a true genius in today's biographics where you're getting
the full story on.
Galileo got la
Galileo.
Galileo was born on February the 15th 1564 and Pisa Italy.
He was the first of six children,
two Vincenzi Dubonnet Judea to Galilee and Gila Galileo,
the gala days.
They were from an ancient and respected family who originated in Florence.
Vicenzo was a world trader who has an abiding interest in philosophy,
science,
and music at the age of four days.
Young Galileo was baptized Catholic.
He was raised according to the strict tenants of the faith,
as was everybody else in the region.
From an early age,
Galileo showed an intense interest in making things.
He was constantly making small little gadgets that would amuse his friends and
his teachers.
These would include wooden animals with moving arms and legs.
He was fascinated by how machines worked and big constantly pulling things apart
and then putting them back together again.
If he was making a machine himself and Dee Dee didn't have a pot is simply
improvise.
When Galileo was 10 years of age,
his father decided to move the family to Florence by now Vincenzo,
who had developed a reputation as a learned and why as men,
despite the demands of business,
he managed to write several books,
the most popular of which was the dialogue of ancient and modern music.
Wealthy people streamed to him to benefit from his knowledge of Greek and Roman
literature and to hear his musical theories.
He was invited to spend some time with Duke.
Albert [inaudible] of Bavaria who lived in Munich,
Germany,
some 300 miles from Florence.
Vicenza was also an active member of the Florentine Camerata.
This were a group of musicians who were experimenting with musical drama,
and that was the genesis of what would become opera.
Galileo and his siblings were therefore raised in an intellectually stimulating
environments.
Vincenzo taught his oldest son how to play a number of musical instruments,
the favorite of which for both was the lute.
Galileo also experimented with drawing and painting and showed great promise in
both of these areas,
his teenage years,
they coincided with the high renaissance period when Italy was being filled with
the works of the great painters,
sculptors,
and architects.
He considered devoting his life to that of an artist,
but his father was king for his son to follow him into the wool Vincenzo.
He had a great passion for the arts,
but he knew that nothing but a solid business.
Korea would secure a stable financial future for his son.
By the time that Galileo had reached as mid teens,
it was apparent to everyone,
including his father,
that his keen mind was destined for greater things than life as a world trader.
Vincenzo sore it.
His duty to encourage Galileo to use his god given intellectual talents to the
fullest extent.
Three has studies if the works of Aristotle Oven Shenzhou hood instilled in his
some the discipline of independent study of observation and experimentation.
Rather than being swayed by what others had already concluded on a matter.
He would independently study the subject for himself and reach his own
conclusions based on those observations.
When he was 15 years of age,
God,
I have attended the Benedictine monastery of Santa Maria de Brossa from the
[inaudible] religion and logic.
After a few months,
however,
he had to return home because he got an infection
when he was 17 Galileo past the bachelor's exam,
which from there to do an entry to the University of Pisa Universities in the
16th century.
They were places attended by members of the only,
the wealthiest families,
and we're generally reserved for those with the ambition of becoming a priest,
a doctor or a professor.
Although Galileo seriously consider the priesthood as a young man,
Galileo or,
well,
I got to Galileo.
His father had decided on a career in medicine for him in order to achieve it.
He first had to obtain a master's degree gala day.
I applied himself to his studies and made excellent progress.
However,
several months into the first year of his medical degree,
he happens to overhear a geometry lecture being delivered by a friend of his
father or Stelio Richie.
He was immediately attracted to the logic and beauty of the math that was being
applied.
When Richie heard from Galileo's father that the boy was fascinated with his
lecture,
he invited him to take his course.
Then Gen z would first made Richard promise not to let Galileo know that he had
consented to him taking the geometry paper and Casey sort as permission to
abandon his medical studies.
In addition to attending geometry lectures,
Galileo worked one on one with Richie is he studied the works of the Greek
mathematician Euclid.
As he became more deeply immersed in the subject together,
Leo became less interested in medicine.
Finally,
he confronted his father and asked him not to stand in the way of his focus on
geometry.
Vicenza he was a realist.
He knew that his son would not prosper as a doctor of his heart,
wasn't in it.
He agreed to support Galileo in his mathematical pursuits.
Often switching to mathematics,
Gallo brought his full intellectual rigor to bat on the subject.
He was an excellent students,
but he still managed to frustrate as professors the inclination to question
everything that his father had instilled in him meant that he would not accept
anything as fact established theories.
They were meaningless and I see it personally pulled them apart,
studied them,
and reached his own conclusions.
It was the Aristotle,
he and scientific method in action,
but even the teenager to question the theories of Aristotle himself.
One day when he was 19 got on there,
happens to be in the piece of cathedral for a mass observance.
After the service,
he was wandering around the building when his attention happens to be caught by
a sculpted bronze lamp located in the Dome of the Cathedral that I'm with
swinging back and forth like a pension.
He observed the,
regardless of the lessening arc of the swing,
the time that it took for each swing remained the same.
To check this observation,
he timed the swings with this pulse.
This led him to the realization that the rhythmic swings of a pendulum,
we're an excellent way to measure the human pulse.
This was the inspiration for the later invention of Galileo's a machine that was
designed to take pulses or a harmonic.
Also later,
this is the first example of Galileo not only observing and testing phenomenon,
but also finding practical applications of his findings.
By 50 95 the financial strain of supporting his son's university studies.
It was too much of in Shenzhou and gala there had to withdraw from the
University of Pisa.
He hadn't yet completed his doctoral degree,
but the budding genius he was not to be deterred.
He embarked upon his own studies by examining the works of the great minds of
ancient Rome and ancient Greece off to dissecting the works of Archimedes.
He wrote his first scientific dissertation in which he describes an invention
that he called the little balance.
This was a hydrostatic scale to measure the water balance.
He also developed a horsepower pump for crop irrigation that was inspired by the
famous Archimedes screw,
just as his father had a decade earlier with his muscle talent.
Galileo began to impress important people with his practical application of
science.
He gained a reputation as an upcoming scientist.
One person who was particularly interested in Galileo's work was the marquee
Geeta balladeer demonte wealthy patron with an abiding interest in astronomy,
mathematics,
and architecture.
Maki began writing together layer and the two maintained a vigorous
correspondence during which Galileo would explain his latest observations and
applications.
Demonte encouraged the 22 year old Galileo to study the center of gravity and
solid bodies,
which ultimately led to the publication of a treatise on the subject.
It was through del Monte.
The Galileo came to the attention of the grand view of Tuscany Ferdinand's the
first dumb a DG in 50 and 89 the grand Duke appointed him as a professor of
mathematics at the University of Pisa.
This was the position that Galileo had been hoping to secure ever since he had
been forced to quit as studies.
At the time,
mathematics was a minor subject of study at university that wasn't even seen as
worthy of study by many people.
Galileo salary was only 68 Florence a year.
Well for lots of any professors that n 600 or more.
In addition,
he was looked down on by them as a young upstart who dared to question the
teachings of the Great Harris startle to then this was akin to blast for me with
the writings of Aristotle being considered the final word on all things.
Ironically,
Galileo was simply following through the teachings of Aristotle himself who
championed independent study and observation while aware that his own theories
could well be over tons as new knowledge was observed.
The most famous example of Galileo not simply accepting one of Aristotle's
theories because it was written down on paper,
I had to do with the speed of falling objects or still solid contended that two
objects of different weights would fall to the ground at different speeds with
the heaviest object falling faster as the story goes.
Got It.
Leo,
he climbed to the top of the leaning tower of Pisa or although the building
thought to have been used may have been the church tower in Delft Tins.
Then he dropped two spheres of different masses to the ground below.
They both at the grounds at the same time disproving Aristotle's theory.
Galileo's experiment at the Tower of Pisa was believed to have been observed by
many of his students and fellow professors of the university.
Still some of the professors refuse to acknowledge that the young man had just
overturned one of Aristotle's theories.
This stubborn refusal to accept him Perico evidence that overturns long
entrenched views is something that Galileo was going to contend with for the
rest of his life.
Now,
just before we continue with today's video,
it is rather appropriately sponsored by brilliance aligning platform.
So whether you want to get to grips with more classical stuff like Galileo and
his dropping things or maybe something a bit more recent like quantum computing
or brilliant is the place to do it.
Now,
you've heard me talk about brilliant before.
They're a learning platform that focuses on active learning.
This is where you're given a short bit of information on a specific scientific
concepts and then you're asked to solve a problem based on that information.
It's an incredibly effective way to learn and right now,
brilliant have actually got something relatively new on their platform called
daily problems.
These are problems that you can do for five minutes a day.
They exercise your brain and they teach you something new.
If you're into learning new things,
which you probably are because you're watching this channel,
brilliant is great for you.
Each problem,
it provides you the context and the framework you need to tackle it.
So that means you can learn concepts by applying them.
That's that active learning stuff.
This sort of short daily practice can lead you from curiosity to mastery in far
less time than you would think.
So got a brilliant.org forward slash biographics and finish your day a little
smarter.
The first 200 of you to do so,
we'll get 20% off your annual subscription and you'll be able to view all of the
problems in the archives.
Let's get back to Galileo because it's about to make some enemies
not long after the tower experiments,
Galileo was approached by a member of the powerful [inaudible] family,
Giovanni Dima [inaudible],
and asked to evaluate a machine that he had invented.
The machine was designed to dredge the Hubble bottoms of lake on to remove the
mucky layer runs,
make them safer for ships to come into Galileo.
Carefully studied the machine.
Oh need to conclude that it was badly designed and is not fit for purpose.
This presented a bit of a problem.
Should it be honest and tell the man that the machine wouldn't work or should he
play Katen with false praise?
The [inaudible] were the most powerful clan in SLE and Galileo was very wary
getting on the wrong side of any of them.
Still,
his loyalty to scientific truth would not allow him to deceive the inventor in a
public forum.
He spelled out what was wrong with the machine and assured everyone presence
that it would not work.
His opinion was born out when the machine proved to be a dismal failure.
Galileo is honesty had created a powerful enemy.
They humiliated.
The digi man was determined to bring Galileo down and he set about getting him
fired from his professorship at the university.
Under the advice of Marquee get Ebaldo Demante yellow layer,
he resigned.
His position done won't say it opened the door to a new posting as the chairman
of mathematics at the University of Pedulla 130 miles northeast of Piza.
This was a big step up together lobe.
He was now making 180 Florence,
which was three times his previous income.
Also,
he no longer had to contend with the ridicule of his fellow professors.
He soon became a very popular lecturer with his classes almost overflowing at
party where he also found the time to work on his inventions and his writings.
He became an expert at applying science step military fortifications,
designing reinforced walls for Fort.
Since mechanically superiors see Jen Gins in 1593 he was invited to Venice to
give advice on the ideal positioning of a rowing ships or is to generate maximum
use of manpower.
In 1593 Galileo developed an undiagnosed illness which kept him in pain,
affected his appetite,
and robbed him of sleep.
These symptoms would affect him for the rest of his life.
Despite your sickness,
he managed to meet as university obligations at the end of his first six year
term at Pad Europe,
he was appointed for a further six years.
By the ends of the 50 nineties Galileo had invented a range of products which
were in demand all over the country.
These included an irrigation pump that required only a single horse to power it
and the sector which was used to measure precise angles lacking the time to
produce each piece himself.
He hired a craftsman named Mark Antonio Mad Celeni to make as inventions.
It wasn't until the mid 50 nineties the Galileo took any serious interest in
astronomy without studying the issue.
He believes in the Ptolemaic theory that the sun and other planets revolved
around the earth.
When a visiting lecturer spoke on the Copernican theory,
which contended that the earth and other planets actually revolve around the
sun,
Galileo did not attend considering the theory to be ridiculous.
Sometime later he was talking with some of his students.
He would attended the lecture.
Most of them didn't accept the new theory,
but there was one person who did.
It was then the Galileo had a simple but profound realization.
Every person who had abandoned the Ptolemaic theory in favor of the Copernican
theory would be subjected to ridicule.
They words therefore only do so on the basis of overwhelming evidence.
He was now obsessed with finding out what that evidence was.
The question of whether the sun or the earth was at the center of the universe
would consume him for the rest of his life.
Even though he continued to teach the theories of taller man his classes,
he became more convinced.
The Copernicus was actually right.
In 1597 he established written communication with the astronomer,
Yohanis Capp Lowe,
who was also an advocate of the Copernican theory.
Capital had published a work supporting good Panaca us and encouraged Galileo to
do the same.
However,
the Italian,
he always worried that doing so would bring upon him the anger of the Catholic
Church,
which held that the earth was undoubtedly at the center of the universe on a
visit to Venice.
Got they ever met a woman by the name of Marina Gamba.
Our relationship developed with marina moving in with him before long.
The child was born in the unwed couple of the first of three two girls and a boy
in 1610 gather.
They left Patois taking his two daughters,
both givens of the conference eventually due to the illegitimate births,
but he left behind his son Vicenzo with marina.
Years later,
marina marries another man,
but God,
I remained friendly with her throughout his lifetime.
In the first decade of the 16 hundreds Galileo continued to invent new
technologies.
In 1604 he observed and discussed capital Supernova.
His talk was so popular that he had to move from the overcrowded lecture theater
to an outside forum so that everyone could hear him.
In 1609 Galilea began working on a machine that would magnify the night sky.
He used to eyeglass lenses.
One concave and the other convex placing them opposite ends of a long metal
tube.
We're looking through this Venetian glass later gold a telescope.
The stars were magnified several times.
The invention was a hit and prominent people from all over Italy clambered to
get a look.
It's this amazing machine which allowed you to see things that are far away.
It's telescopes.
They were also a profitable sideline for Galileo who sold them to merchants.
You found them useful both at sea and as items of trade.
The invention reflected positively on the University of Padua prompting the
boards who offer Galileo a lifetime professorship and increase his salary to a
thousand and Florence.
Before long Galileo had improved his telescope and send it was able to magnify
up to 30 times.
This enables him to look through it at the moon.
He discovered that rather than being perfectly round and smooth,
as Aristotle had written,
it was rough and filled with craters and valleys.
Is Telescope also in,
they would Galileo to identify and observe the moons of other planets.
During the period between January the eighth and the 14 1610 he discovered that
Jupiter had four moons.
Then in July of that same year,
he became the first person to identify the rings around Saturn.
Though he didn't quite realize what they were at the time.
Later that year,
he identified the Jupiter and Mars had phases which were similar to the moon.
There is telescope.
Galileo was able to identify that there were many,
many more stars than had originally been thought and that therefore the universe
was simply much larger than previously thought.
This upset too many people who thought that through his telescope,
Galileo was using some form of trickery to make new discoveries.
In 1609 he was invited to move to the palace of the grand.
You can Florence.
He except is moving back to his home region of Tuscany,
has dropped now involved with giving lectures to princes and other members of
the royal family,
not them got having to lecture.
He now had the freedom to study and write books.
By 1615 there was a rising tide of opposition to Galileo.
Many of his discoveries had flown in the face of accepted church doctrine,
which was closely aligned with the teachings of Aristotle.
People began asserting that his findings were at odds with the scriptures,
which were the revealed word of God.
Galileo responded by writing that the Bible was not a scientific textbook,
but where it touched on science,
it was actually in harmony with his findings.
He thought that people had simply interpreted the scriptures and correctly the
of the Galileo wrote soon found its way into the hands of his enemies,
particularly the Dominican's of some mark.
They viewed what he had written as heresy,
and so they made sure that a copy of the letter got in front of the pope in
Rome.
The pope called for the leading Dominican to come and give testimony about
Galileo.
There's mountain made the most of the opportunity telling lies to paint Galileo
and his followers as blasphemous.
Galileo.
He was not coward.
He considered those who spoke against him as ignorant fools,
and he sat out to defend himself to do so.
He traveled to the center of the culture in itself,
Rome,
he appearance before the Holy Office on February the 26th 1616 and was ordered
to never again teach that the sun was the center of the universe is reasoned
arguments.
In his defense,
it fell on deaf ears.
Galileo remained in rooms,
you argue with his detractors.
This was not pleasing to his patron back in the court of Tuscany who felt that
the conflicts could cause a rift between them and Rome.
In June,
Galileo,
he finally complied.
Returning to Florence,
the stress of defending his reputation.
It had taken a toll on Galileo.
He was constantly plagued with physical pain and spend increasing amounts of
time.
Bedridden.
In 1617 he moved to a hilltop village just outside of Florence.
In order to benefit from the rural app,
he continued to study the heavens,
but was now far more guarded about what he wrote.
Then in 1618 his elements worsened.
He was confined to bed for several weeks and he became extremely weak.
By 1624 there was a new pope,
urban the eighth as a cardinal.
He had expressed admiration for Galileo bus.
He had never agreed with the Copernican theory that's slightly recovered.
Galileo was convinced to make a pilgrimage to Rome in order to meet with the
pope in order to assess his standing with pontiff urban receive too well.
Even presenting a Madeline's promising a pension gather.
They will also notice that the church officials around the room were far less
hostile to him than they had been before.
He felt confidence believing that the new pope had ease the pressure on him.
In 1629 Galileo wrote a masterful work dialogue concerning the two chief weld
systems,
which presented a dialogue between three men on the merits of the Ptolemaic and
Copernican theories before it can be published.
Yantra presenters,
the chief censor of the press in Rome.
He was forced to make changes that presented the Ptolemaic theory and a far more
favorable light and to state clearly that the idea is expressed were not facts,
but simply opinions.
Galileo,
he made the changes,
but a series of delays prevented the book's publication until 1632
the new book brought out
the ire of the enemies of the now 68 year old Galileo.
When pope urban got to read it,
he became enraged.
He became convinced that one of the three debates is in the book was based on
himself and he considered this to be a insult of the highest level.
In August of 1632 all copies of the book sold in bookstores were seized in the
printer was ordered to cease publication.
Then in September,
Galileo was ordered to appear before the holy Roman inquisition after stalling
due to El healthy.
Finally headed to Rome to faces inquisitor's on January the 20th 1633 he had to
wait until April the 12th to appear before the vice commissioner of the only
office and to other examiners for preliminary questioning.
It was stated that his book was in direct violation of the 1616 OFI had taken
not to publicly discuss the teachings of Copernicus.
In his defense,
Galileo contended that the book was simply a dialogue between the two theories
and did not favor the view that the sun was at the center of the universe.
The second interview was held on April the 30th this time Galileo was more
conciliatory,
agreeing that the arguments in favor of the Copernican theory come to the heir
of the reader with far greater force and power than should have been imparted to
them by someone who regarded them as inconclusive.
The interview concluded with the examiners agreeing to give Galileo time to
prepare his full defense.
That hearing was held on June the 20 fast before he could fully develop his
defense.
He was asked point blank whether he had ever held to the Copernican theory.
He owns it,
that he had initially been in different to both theories,
but after careful study now believed in the wisdom of the Ptolemaic theory.
This was clearly not true and none of the examiners believed him.
The following day.
He was sentenced to prison with the time to be decided later and his book was
banned.
He was then made to read a statement of apology on bended knee.
Pope urban seemed satisfied with the south com Galileo who'd been both condemned
and humiliated.
The pope decided that the imprisonment,
so which Galileo had been sentenced could be carried out by way of home
detention.
That's the Grand Duke of Tuscany is villa near room.
However,
the Galileo was desperate to live out his last years in Florence where his
family were located.
He wrote to the pope,
begging has indulgence,
which he was granted he would be confined to the villa of a powerful friends.
After five months he was permitted to return to his own villa,
Galileo,
his final years remarks by ill-health by 1637 he was nearly totally blinds
before his site was gone completely.
He managed to complete his last stands in his view is most outstanding work
entitled discourses and Mathematical Demonstrations of two new sciences under
the rules of a sentence.
He could not publish it in Italy and so the manuscript was smuggled to Amsterdam
and publish that during his last day as the blind genius received many visitors
to his villa.
He died on January the eighth 1642 at the age of 77 he had been fighting fever
and heart problems for months,
nearly a hundred years later with this brilliant having finally been recognized,
his remains were removed from the chaplet,
Santa Croce and relocated to a much more elaborate mausoleum inside the church
during move three fingers and a tooth removed from his remains,
one of these fingers.
The middle finger from Galileo's righthand is currently on exhibition at the
Museo,
Galileo and Florence,
Italy and monuments was also erected with a bust of Galileo and two fingers
representing his monumental achievements in the worlds of astronomy and
geometry.
So I really hope you found that video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos just like this several times a week.
So hit that subscribe button and don't click that bell as well.
So you find out when we put out a new video,
also,
please do check out brilliant.
They're a fantastic sponsor or letting us make longer stuff like this.
So please click on them in the link below and as always,
thank you for watching.